dans le ciel de las vegas sur la strip
la marque cirque du soleil brille avec
éclat peu importe où l'on use encore
vagues sms cirque du soleil en fait une
expression ici qui dissertent de vegas
c'est pour montrer comment on y perd
renie le cirque et la ville on a été le
précurseur d'amener du divertissement
des spectacles grandioses à las vegas
pas étonnant donc que ce soit ici que le
cirque et choisit de remonter en piste
en amérique du nord d'après l'équipe
ceux causés par la pandémie
l'acrobate caroline lauzon fait les
derniers ajustements avant d'en fait
pouvoir remonter sur scène après un
entracte qui lui ont paru interminables
à la pandémie a mis tellement question
dans la tête de tout le monde que on
n'était pas sûr que ça a l'air bien donc
c'est quand on est d'autant plus heureux
de revenir le soleil se lève
car en mars 2020 le cirque du soleil
avec 44 production présenté un peu
partout sur la planète
elles se sont toutes retrouvées sur
pause du jour au lendemain et à l'instar
de la ville du vice
le cirque revue en quelques semaines ses
revenus se tarir une traversée du désert
qui le tellement fragilisé que le
fleuron québécois a été sauvé in
extremis de la faillite
c'était de loin la pire crise de
l'histoire du cercle et qu'on puisse
rebondir il le faire avec autant de
vitalité non seulement on va le faire à
vegas mais on va le faire aussi avec nos
spectacles de tournée au cours des
prochaines semaines
tous prêts pour un nouveau départ avant
la pandémie
le cirque rayonner un peu partout sur la
planète marche toujours et c'est reparti
après la chine la république dominicaine
l'angleterre c'est maintenant à vegas
que le cirque se relève
ensuite ce sera au tour d'alegria à
houston au texas et de khouzaa dans le
vieux port de montréal à partir d'avril
2022 au plaisir est un soulagement pour
des artistes comme la nageuse gabrielle
lepage rencontré après la générale
devant public du spectacle aux ailes
étaient impatients de replonger je
pensais même pas pendant lapan
amy que je m'ennuyais autant ce les
publics le meut complètement nourris ça
a été mémorable j'en avais les larmes
aux yeux
pour tous ceux qui avaient misé gros à
las vegas la crise des derniers mois a
été un choc
après la pluie le beau temps au cirque
du soleil on veut y croire
les acrobates vous le diront ce qui
compte c'est pas la chute mais
l'atterrissage et surtout de pouvoir se
relever ici n'est bien alexandre
chartier radio canada las vegas